[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i'm your host paul and with oscar
isaac's casting as moonlight breaking
the internet this week
i thought i'd take an in-depth look at
the character to tell you everything you
need to know about him
now moonlight is often labeled as
marvel's answer to batman
and though this is true in a lot of
respects he goes far beyond that in my
opinion
over the last couple of years the
character has really switched direction
from the dark knight
and i think as we go through this you'll
see that there are a lot of differences
oscar isaac was a popular fan cast for
the dark knight
but with robert pattinson ben affleck
and michael keaton currently over at dc
doing the lord's work
i'm glad that isaac found another role
that he feels like a perfect fit for
now moonlight aka mark spector
originally appeared in werewolf fine
night 32
all the way back in 1975. created by
doug monk
and artist don pillman he was originally
supposed to be a villain that would go
head to head with a titular character
and this is what the initial arc
centered around after the copies went to
print
editor marv wolfman and len wine liked
him so much
that they decided to place him in other
arcs and they switched him from a
villain to a hero
which is where we are pretty much at
today throughout his long and rich
history
we've learned several things about
spectre and his origin story begins
all the way back in chicago illinois
mark specter was born the son of a
jewish rabbi
and he and his father had a strained
relationship mark believed that his dad
was a coward
because he fled the east in order to
escape the holocaust
marx stated that he should have remained
in fort and this led to him enrolling in
boxing classes
before he switched his attention to the
us marine corps
spectre was an excellent soldier that
was pretty much unrivaled in the field
and the characters served as part of
force recon which is one of the most
infamous u.s reconnaissance groups
spectre which just so happens to be
another word for ghost
ended up leaving the marines and not
long after he became a mercenary
that operated in black ops for the cia
so
not a guy that you really want to meet
down a back alley or
well ever now isaacs himself is half
jewish
and i really think that with his build
and overall look that he's gonna fill
the shoes perfectly
as we explore his backstory through the
disney show
now every hero of course has a defining
moment and specters comes in when he
stumbles across an archaeological dig in
egypt
those at the site had uncovered an
ancient temple that was built to worship
the egyptian god of the moon
who we learn is called konchu now it
turns out that raul bushman
the man who had hired spectre was
actually after the treasures at the site
and he killed several of the
archaeologists there
expect to challenge bushmen to a fight
but ended up getting his ass handed to
him and he was left for dead
stupid bushmen no never leave anyone
make sure you see them die
now specter was found by the locals who
worshipped the moon god
and they carried him to their temple and
placed him before the statue of konchu
the guard then appeared to spectre and
it offered him a deal
he would get another chance at life if
he became an avatar for the god on earth
and spectre accepted this wrapped in the
silver shroud surrounding the statue
he went after bushman and defeated him
in the process
specter then returned to america took up
the mantle of moon knight
and became a crime fighter and the
reason that moon knight gets so many
comparisons to batman is because spectre
ended up investing the money that he'd
made as a mercenary
and the character gained a small fortune
that led to him becoming a
multi-millionaire
similar to batman spectre also fights
criminals with gadgets and gizmos
and even has a number of projectiles
which are sometimes referred to as moon
rungs
yeah i wonder where they got that idea
from anyway on top of this
spectre adopted the identity of stephen
grant in order to continue his business
dealings
this was pretty much a playboy persona
that he used to masquerade and high
society with
he also developed another one called
jake lockley who was a taxi driver in
the city
these personalities combined allowed him
to accumulate
a lot of wealth whilst it also allowed
him to keep his ear close to the
criminal element that existed in chicago
though spectre doesn't have any
superpowers per se
he does have a very particular set of
skills
skills that he's acquired over a very
long career
skills that have made him a nightmare
for people like you
if you let my dora go now that will be
this
sorry i i don't know what's come over me
now now obviously as he was
initially a boxer that moved on to
become a us marine
he's picked up a number of tactical
fighting techniques and military skills
that means he's an expert at
hand-to-hand combat moon knight has
actually killed quite a lot of people
due to his past
but at one point in the comics he did
vow to never take another life
which is probably the avenue that
they'll go with in the show
in addition to boxing specter has also
trained in the arts of ninjutsu
muay thai judo kung fu and karate
because of his training he's able to
perform at an olympic level
and he's also a master in acrobatics
thus
traversal around the city is very very
easy for him
now he did mention the moon ranks before
but on top of this the character also
carries with him a truncheon
and a bosteph he's also equipped with
bowlers
throwing irons and crescent darts that
are shaped like scarabs
moonai at one point also upgraded his
costume to be lined with adamantium
and this provided him with an almost
bulletproof level of protection
moonai is a master pilot and thus he's
pretty much the perfect all-rounder
i think that they have a lot of avenues
that they can take him down in the
series
now if you still haven't subscribed to
the channel then this is our obligatory
reminder that we do videos like this
every day
and you know what we'd love to have you
as part of the community
we're also giving away three copies of
the marvel phase one box set on the 30th
of october
and all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is subscribe to
notifications on and drop a comment
below
we're trying to hit the 400 000 mark by
the end of the year
and it would mean the world to have you
watching the videos
anyway thanks for sitting through that
now where expected diverts from batman
quite heavily
is that he actually gained superpowers
at one point which were triggered by
certain phases of the moon i guess when
your life is a gift from a literal god
that a lot comes with it and the fuller
the moon got the the more specters
abilities of strength
and endurance increased now i know that
batman
in certain recent dc comics is confirmed
to be a meta human
but i've just burned that out of my mind
along with the rest of rebirth
i'm sorry yeah it's fine it's it's just
not me this is sort of how i see moon
knight as well
and he did eventually lose his powers
after consu stated that
he was disobedient towards him now it is
possible that specter
simply imagined the entire thing about
konchu and he could have self-hypnotized
himself into believing that the god gave
him another chance
that he also has abilities because of
this the comics have dealt with several
aspects of mark's mental health
his multiple personalities and overall
there's
a large amount of the comic book
community that believe he could just be
a crazy guy
who imagined konchu coming to him the
books have gone back and forth on this
and at one point his personalities were
even diagnosed as being all parts of
konshu
such as the pathfinder the one who lives
on hearts and the embracer
thus it is possible that his possession
by the god
caused him to try and rationalize what
was happening to him and he invented
these personalities in order to
comprehend it
whether he he's truly a manifestation of
konchu
or if he hallucinated everything is
something that we don't know for
definite
but in my opinion the series is
definitely gonna tackle it
i'm so glad that we have an act of the
caliber of isaac betraying this
as i think he could definitely handle it
really well and take the character
down some dark roads now moon knight has
also adopted the monaco mr knight
and he uses this to help police
investigate crimes
and well just looks really cool moon
knight has also been a member of the
avengers
and it does seem like marvel are
actually introducing a lot of new
characters to slot into the group
whether it's the falcon moonlight
spider-man doctor strange captain marvel
she-hulk or ms marvel the studio really
seemed to be putting the pieces in place
to have a completely new group
by 2024. as for the show we know that
egyptian filmmaker mohammed dayab
will be direct in the majority of the
show and as
he's egyptian you can bet that we will
probably get an adaptation of the
original bushmen storyline to kickstart
the series
i think marvel have picked a brilliant
team to bring moonlight to the screen
and i'm very excited to see what happens
next as for the release date of the show
we don't know if a definite when it will
air just yet
but for the moment i think 2022 is a
safe bet
i know that falcon and winter soldier
was pushed back
but the studio have a much better hold
on the pandemic now
so i think things will get rolling along
on schedule
anyway that's everything you need to
know on moonlight i just want to give a
huge shout out to the wiki created by
fandom for putting all this information
together obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the character
and what you want to see in the show so
make sure you comment below and let me
know
if you enjoyed this video then please
drop a thumbs up also
check out our breakdown of everything we
know so far about season three of the
boys which is going to be linked at the
end
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat just on a discord
server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been paul i'll
see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you